THAT WOULD BE A MAJOR PICKUP FO
THEM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
NOT OF THE COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
JOHN FADIMAN, THE PITTSBURGH
POST- GAZETTE HAS ENDORSED DR.
OZ IN WHAT WAS A SCATHING
EDITORIAL LAYING OUT ALL THE
STRUGGLES FOR THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY, AND IN REFUSING T
RELEASE HIS MEDICAL RECORDS IS
TROUBLING, IT SUGGESTS AN
IMPULSE TO CONCEAL IN A MISTRUS
OF THE PEOPLE IT CONTINUES,
DESPITE HIS HOODIES AND SHORTS
HAS LITTLE EXPERIENCE IN HOLDIN
REAL JOBS OR FACING THE PROBLEM
OF WORKING PEOPLE THE EDITORIAL
CLOSES WITH THIS, IN A RACE ON
WHICH MUCH DEPENDS, AND LITTLE
IS CERTAIN, DR. OZ HAS SHOWN HE
IS READY TO LEAD AND DELIVER FO
PENNSYLVANIA.
TO RELEASE VIOLENT CRIMINALS
WHILE ON THE PAROLE BOARD.
WANTS TO RELEASE THIRD OR MORE
PENNSYLVANIA PRISONERS, AND
NEWLY RESURFACED AUDIO NOW SHOW
SUGGESTING THAT REPUBLICAN
VOTERS, PEOPLE IN PENNSYLVANIA,
YOU'RE A BUNCH OF RACIST.
THERE ARE SOME IN THE REPUBLICA
PARTY THAT ARE UNREACHABLE.
NATIONALISM, SINA PHOBIA,
HOMOPHOBIA, I MEAN THAT'S THE
STREP SOUTHERN STRATEGY, RIGHT?
>> ISN'T THIS THE SAME GUY THEY
CHASED AN INNOCENT
AFRICAN-AMERICAN OUT JOGGING,
DOING NOTHING WRONG DOWN THE
STREET AND ACCORDING TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL HE TOOK A SHOTGUN AN
POINTED IT RIGHT AT HIS CHEST
AND HELD HIM HOSTAGE UNTIL THE
POLICE CAME.
HE IS MY KIND OF GUY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT ABOUT HIS.
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS REALLY GOOD.
I THOUGHT HE KNEW IT HE WAS
DOING GREAT I THOUGHT HE WAS
STRONG.
HE IS EVERYTHING THAT HE APPEAR
TO BE COMING YOU KNOW WHERE HE
STANDS, HE IS GREAT COURAGE.
HE HAS NO ELECTIONS TO SAY WHAT
HE THINKS.
HE IS MY KIND OF GUY.
>> MY KIND OF GUY.
DR. OZ IS HIT IN THIS RACE BY
THREE POINTS ACCORDING TO THE
LATEST INSIDER ADVANTAGE POLL.
STRUGGLING AS MUCH AS EVER.
THE COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA
.
DO YOU THINK YOU WILL HAVE ANY
IMPACT ON THE RACE?
THEY CANNOT DEFEND THE RADICAL
VIEWS.
I DON'T THINK BARACK OBAMA CAN
EITHER.
THESE EXTREME POSITIONS ARE OUT
OF TOUCH WITH PENCIL.
BUT THEY DID IS PUSHED AGAINST
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PAROLE
BOARD TO GET MURDERERS OUT.
HE'S ACKNOWLEDGED IF HE HAD A
MAGIC WAND HE'D WANT TO GET RID
OF LIFE IN PRISON FOR FELONY
MURDER.
OR 1,000 CARJACKING.
THIS CITY IS IN UNIMAGINABLE ME
SPREAD HERE'S THE PART THAT
CATCHES ME OFF FOR IT OFFGUARD
RIGHT AFTER THAT DEBATE, WHEN
THERE WAS ISSUE AFTER ISSUE
AFTER ISSUE WHERE HE COULD NOT
DEFEND TAKING RADICAL POSITION
HE WAS ABLE TO RAISE MILLIONS O
DOLLARS BECAUSE ALL THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO IS CONTROL
THE SENATE SO HELP ME FIGHT BAC
GO TO DR. OZ.COM.
IT IS THE BELIEF THAT BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT THEY DON'
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE KITCHEN
TABLE ISSUES OF CRIME, THE
BORDER, THE ECONOMIC CRISES WE
ARE FACING THAT ARE GETTING
WORSE BY THE DAY.
GAS PRICES WENT UP AGAIN TODAY.
IT IS GOING TO GET BACK TO $5 A
GALLON IN PENNSYLVANIA AND
PROBABLY MUCH OF THE COUNTRY IF
WE DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
TO GET IT LATER IN THE DEBATE
WHEN HE SAID HE WAS NEVER FOR
EMINENT MORATORIUM ON FRACKING.
WE HAVE MULTIPLE TAPES, WE
PLAYED THERE MANY TIMES.
HE WANTS NO RESTRICTIONS ON
ABORTION FOR IT IS HAS NEVER
BEEN A CANDIDATE IN THE SENATE
CAN THINK OF THAT'S ADVOCATED T
RELEASE MORE CONVICTED MURDERER
IN VIOLENT CRIMINALS THAN HIM.
GET THIS STRAIGHT GRAIN, THICK
LIPS, HE WANTS TAXPAYERS PLATE
PAY FOR HEROIN INJECTION SITE
SPREAD AND THEN YOU HAVE THAT
LITTLE SHOTGUN INCIDENTS AS HE
DARES TO CALL REPUBLICANS RACIS
RATE AND A REACTION THAT?
TO GET YOU JUST LISTED A LITANY
OF PROBLEMS THAT HE HAS WITH LA
ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S WHY THE PATERNAL ORDER O
POLICE INTEREST ME.
HIS HOME TIME PAPER WHICH IS A
FABULOUS PAPER, GENUINELY
DOESN'T INTEREST REPUBLICAN
PRAYER THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH AS
WELL.
EVERYBODY IS SAYING THE SAME
THING.
LET THE COPS DO THEIR JOB.
MAKE PROSECUTORS DO THEIR JOB.
ELECT POLITICIANS WE SHOULD BOT
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM VOTERS, H
HAS NOT DONE THAT YET ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL HE'S NOT ASKING
ANSWER QUESTION FROM THE THAT
DEBATE WAS THE FIRST AND ONLY
TIME HE WILL TAKE QUESTIONS FRO
A BIRD THEY WE'RE TRAINED TO
ROUND-THE-CLOCK OUT BUT DIDN'T
GET AWAY WITH IT.
NOW PENNSYLVANIA I AM LOOKING A
THE RESULTS OF THE DEBATE
THINKING OF WHAT HE CAN'T ANSWE
QUESTIONS FRED HE DOESN'T HAVE
GOOD DEFENSES FOR THEM.
HE'S DONE GREAT AND 140
CHARACTER TWEET.
THAT'S GREAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
BE THE AOC OF THE SENATE, BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO LET HIM GET
THERE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT WE DO NOT HAV
A REPUBLICAN SENATOR IN NORTH
CAROLINA OR ON THE ATLANTIC
COAST.
THERE HAS BEEN A REPUBLICAN
SENATOR IN PENNSYLVANIA MOST OF
MY LIFE.
THIS IS A STATE THAT BECAUSE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT WE WANT A
REPUBLICAN PRESENCE HERE TO MAK
SURE IT IS WELL REPRESENTED
ALONG WITH OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE OTHER ISSUES.
BIG CITIES LIKE PHILADELPHIA
THAT HAS ISSUES ALONG AROUND
POVERTY.
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THESE ISSUES
ARE ADDRESSED READ REPUBLICANS
INTO IT WHILE.
WHEN BARACK OBAMA WAS THERE
CAMPAIGNING FOR THAT IT WAS
BARACK OBAMA WHO REFERRED TO TH
PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA IS BITTE
AMERICANS THAT CLING TO THEIR
GOD, GUN, BIBLE, AND RELIGION.
SOMEBODY IN THE MEDIA MIGHT HAV
ENOUGH GUTS TO ASK IF HE STILL